humor has gone off war rebellion and
revolution for more than a decade I've
been outside Britain reporting on some
of the big events shaping lives and
views inside back in Britain also known
as the United Kingdom I haven't lived
here since 2005 and want to find out
just how much has changed over the past
twelve years
[Music]
don't touch it think the headscarf
straight away give some image keep all
of your legs we're gonna roll back up
again
people expect differently to actually
the kind of personality that comes out
on the other side stop there yeah very
snoby today and I think that's probably
misconception I had like before I was
missing but you know these women in
headscarves all kind of these choir
stay-at-home mums it's a sit home
cooking and cleaning and that were just
controlled by their husband when I
considered Islam hadn't made that
decision by considered it and I thought
about wearing a headscarf I thought
would have no way no way I'm ever going
to wear hijab no way
I mean I'd like to think about why I
didn't want to wear it and it was sanity
it was just the fact that I was worried
about what people would think and how
they treat me
would you like coffee oh yeah why not
that'd be great I enjoy me to hold him
whilst you're doing anything or you
happy to die Khadijah is a mum a
businesswoman and a convert to Islam how
much they weigh I don't know and she's
talking to me all about what it means to
be British and Muslim in the UK today
I'm so happy and fortunate that I've
been born in Britain and I'm British and
to have converted Islam in a country
that is accepting of it like I do think
they are accepting all that that doesn't
mean I don't have never felt vulnerable
I was walking and passed a shopping
centre it went through my mind if
someone was to attack me now I'd be very
vulnerable because I've got him attached
to me on my front and I probably
wouldn't have had that thought when I
wasn't Muslim I probably just wouldn't
have thought I would have pocket become
a victim so it does go through my mind
it's possible but I'm more likely to
become a victim although I don't feel
victimized clenched move new kidney push
away and then your spin bucket
khadijah teaches kickboxing she's a
black belt in my time and runs
female-only on classes when up and
Muslim women are encouraged to join iya
what are you trying to get for these
women confidence self defense
just knowing they would be able to spend
themselves if they needed to and just an
environment where I can train really
comfortably I think that's the main
thing
options of trade has anybody else would
do the Muslim women themselves feel more
vulnerable losing oh yeah I think so I
think like when you speak to them a bit
whether they are worried about when they
are aware that they could more likely to
be able to switch and this is also about
develops as well yeah so obviously a lot
of these moves you'd be able to use and
softer them could be just trying to
prove to me it's not just self-defense
she's teaching go to the console um yeah
if you think this is 30 seconds it's
about smashing stereotypes
- do you think people are surprised when
they see Muslim woman wearing the hijab
teaching be completely surprised totally
not what they're expecting at all I
think they're expecting ID I don't know
when I say that sometimes every topic on
the t-shirt and I call you chief at
family school children like wall
sometimes I call me out like oh what do
you see each white I like Kim popping oh
oh and then I like double check bug
she wearing hijab like did I see right
see I think it does it's not what people
expect it's all function you've got
punch ha ha ha I'm here as well and now
the other half so now left like [ __ ] 10
9 8 7 6 5 now protect your head and keep
your hands up 5 4 3 2 same thing is
asleep in the car that's it khadijah
husband Karim is British though born in
Algeria he's seen how anti-muslim
sentiments grown these days yeah
lot of things change a lot of these a
increase of our you know hate about
Muslims and stuff like that it's going
on but if you look at it 20 years ago it
wasn't at Kings Cross where hundreds
were moved to safety together we looked
at the litany of terror strikes in
Europe and Britain Russell Square what
was left of the number 30 bus across the
very heart of London they were shocked
confusion and an almost palpable sense
of fear among those caught up in the
moment each one they say Stokes
Islamophobia they're expecting the same
after the Manchester bombing I guess I
started looking up Muslims didn't know
waiting to see always this isn't
something me to be scared of is that
personal risk to us do you find your
beard gets any reaction well you were a
little bit worried weren't you about
growing up that's how I was yeah was so
paranoid to be honest with you because I
said if I won't be people when you look
at me like hmm
I'm in tube station you know you start
thinking like this guy just got to blow
up himself if they're trying to fight
you
and they're trying to resist it you just
go down to the floor as well right and
then they'll come down with you okay so
learning how to fend off attacks has
become all too important jab hook like
it
okay